-Performing "This Morning"
from his album "Drones,"
here's Terrace Martin,
Arin Ray, and Smino.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Birds chirping ]
-♪ Okay, we been raw,
St. Louis to Crenshaw ♪
♪ Crenshaw, Crenshaw, Crenshaw ♪
-♪ Woke up this morning ♪
♪ Found my peace of mind ♪
♪ And, finally,
I can say to you ♪
♪ That I ♪
♪ Feel good this morning ♪
♪ No, I can't deny ♪
♪ So, finally,
I can lay with you ♪
♪ And feel ♪
♪ Feel the pleasure ♪
♪ Finally do what lovers do ♪
♪ With you, baby ♪
♪ Ride for two ♪
♪ Don't you know? ♪
♪ So we can roll ♪
♪ How we want to, yeah ♪
♪ Set fire to the pavement ♪
♪ They bound to drown ♪
♪ And just do what I say,
do what I say ♪
♪ And my baby got her own ways ♪
♪ I'm tellin' y'all
she ain't even playin' ♪
♪ And ain't no problems
from her man ♪
♪ No, no, she ain't worried ♪
-♪ She ain't worried ♪
♪ Unh ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Da, da-da, da ♪
♪ Ahhh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Da-da, da ♪
♪ Da ♪
-♪ Why you never ready ♪
♪ When I called you ♪
♪ Told you I'd be on my way? ♪
♪ Two hours ♪
♪ You still dancing ♪
♪ In the mirror ♪
♪ Come outside ♪
♪ I got a minimalist shawty ♪
♪ She don't want me
smoking my Grabba Leaf,
but her Banana Leaf's sorry ♪
♪ I was rollin' up
on her vanity ♪
♪ She got to
telling these stories ♪
♪ How she finally
found some sanity ♪
♪ And these hatin' girls must be
off that good cane,
that Danity ♪
♪ And it dawned on me ♪
♪ Like 6:00 a.m.
over dewy grass ♪
♪ And my doobie rolled ♪
-♪ She might be ♪
-♪ Addicted to the lights ♪
-♪ A victim of the likes ♪
-♪ She might be ♪
-♪ A rid of my vibe ♪
♪ She colder than shoulders
of gold-digging ♪
♪ When a broke dude
approaching ♪
♪ But she colder
when someone like me
ain't around to come light up ♪
-♪ Set fire to the pavement ♪
♪ They bound to drown ♪
♪ Oh, just do what I say,
do what I say ♪
♪ And my baby got her own ways ♪
♪ I'm tellin' y'all
she ain't even playin' ♪
♪ And ain't no problems
from her man ♪
♪ No, no, she ain't worried ♪
-♪ She ain't worried ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ Set fire to the pavement ♪
♪ They bound to drown ♪
♪ Oh, just do what I say,
do what I say ♪
♪ No, no ♪
♪ Mm, I'm tellin'
y'all she ain't even playin' ♪
♪ Ain't no problems ♪
♪ Ain't no problems
from her man ♪
-♪ She ain't worried ♪
-♪ I'm her man ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Da, da-da, da ♪
♪ Ahhh, ooh ♪
♪ Da-da, da ♪
♪ Da ♪
-Drums.
[ Cheers and applause ]